hey what's going on it's bill burr and
it's time for the Monday morning podcast
from Monday January 16 2017 what's going
on how are you everybody and a happy ma
Luther King Day to everybody you know
happy Martin Luther King Day you know
for for those usually that mean some to
you for those who just yeah you know
it's another day off
that's just like when I Giorgio abies
birthday in February do we get those
days off um the two Whitey's they're the
two Whitey's in February I believe it's
in February right during Black History
Month you still got a shoehorn George
Washington Day and Lincoln's birthday in
there correct then you got another
whitey and why got another whitey and uh
and my was st. Patrick huh you
pasty-faced [ __ ] son of a [ __ ] Yeah
right
then in April who do you got oh here
comes Peter Cottontail hopping down the
bunny trail right with his ol little
white bunny yes right then what do you
got you got in May who said is that Abe
Vigoda day I don't know I've run out
somewhere around there those are weird
the dog days of the year it's like
[ __ ] you know Flag Day then I always
get Memorial Day and Labor Day Memorial
Day is is May right Memorial yeah
Memorial Day is in May we recognize all
the veterans you know that fought for
your freedom so you can sit around eat
[ __ ] dip and [ __ ] right changing all
your [ __ ] VCR tapes over to [ __ ]
DVDs and then to a little [ __ ] stick
whatever the [ __ ] it is you do that day
right and you got July 4th so everybody
can go around and [ __ ] you know trade
stories about their uncle that blew his
[ __ ] fingers off because he never got
married he was trying to impress his
nephews and nieces right
right so you see that right there son
you see that right there that's why I
told you your Uncle Jimmy ain't no
[ __ ] good alright I don't wanna quit
your crap all right I want to hear it no
more ain't going over uncle Jimmy's okay
it's over there with loose [ __ ] women
and he's playing with them firecrackers
all right so that's July 4th then August
August is kind of like a month that's up
for grabs no Jewish holidays no hey
remember Jesus did this for you what do
you say to him Muslims what do you got
you got something that month how about
you Buddhist Buddhist don't give a [ __ ]
right they're like hey man like every
day's for everybody and it's just like
as long as we're sitting around and
feeling the breeze that's what I'm
trying to be you know I'm trying to be
that person today was gonna be my tenth
day in a row to meditate but I didn't I
woke up late and had to take my lady
over to the doctors and and I just I
just got up late yeah I had this [ __ ]
weird-ass dream too
this weird dream Rose went out my back
porch I was watching these helicopters
flying in formation and dive-bomb in my
neighborhood I was like what the [ __ ]
are they doing that for and then one of
them lost control and I had this weird
view from my house that I've never had
before and it was just basically the
cockpit you know and the engine that
part and the skids no main rotor no tail
no tail rotor nothing else and for some
reason it wasn't tipping over in falling
to the ground like a [ __ ] trashcan or
most likely inverting just [ __ ] it
just went straight and it's sort of
landed and I ran down there I was in my
underwear cuz you're always in your
underwear and then in your dreams right
you never have your pants on it's so
[ __ ] weird there's a with mine
there's always that level of humiliation
no matter what's going on I can anyway
so the [ __ ] thing lands so I run up
but now I'm thinking like wait a minute
do I want to see the carnage that is in
there and then all these people showed
up with like cell phone cameras and
stuff and I was standing there my
underwear and I ran home that was that
they go there's your dream to interpret
for the week alright because I'm not
going to ther
be anymore because I spent enough
[ __ ] money you know with somebody
daydreaming with the goddamn notebook
right and none of them ever looked like
that brought on The Sopranos let's be
honest right yeah so I started I woke up
late all right so I need to [ __ ]
relax
quiet my mind make it more of a still
pond whenever a rock falls into the pond
what happens the waters Ripple yes the
waters Ripple and if too many rocks fall
in what happens this starts to be a
storm and this is what I want you to pay
attention to today during today's
meditation it's your brain a still pond
or can you hear this screaming watery
death of 1,200 passengers going under
the water of your mind sorry I lost it I
don't know what the [ __ ] I was talking
about anyways um I have some apologies
this week apology number one I owe an
apology to the [ __ ] Atlanta Falcons I
owe an apology to the Houston Texans I
Meryl Streep evidently according to
Twitter according to one person all
right let's start with the Seattle
Seahawks right you know I thought those
were gonna be the dirty filthy stinking
disease-carrying birds that were gonna
win that game I said last week and I
kind of quote you know who got off easy
this weekend the New England Patriots
and the Seattle Seahawks because the
Cowboys and the Packers are gonna beat
the [ __ ] out of each other and the
Steelers and the [ __ ] Chiefs are
gonna beat the [ __ ] out of each other
right and then all we got to do is play
the winner assuming that these two teams
were just gonna waltz to the AFC and NFC
championship game as if that is a given
well let's start with the Atlanta
Falcons I picked the wrong dirty Birds
very impressive win and I know Seattle
fans gonna be like we had some major
injuries which they did coming into the
game and then they lost another guy I
understand
that okay I totally understand that
Seattle fans are 100% right Christ I can
hear you crying from here your stadium
is so loud oh my god of those Seattle
see they're so [ __ ] LA I'm so sick of
SPN [ __ ] like just ignoring that
entire fact they just don't do you know
what it is you know it is they can't
they have the ability to separate
themselves from the truth that's what I
really respect from ESPN as they can
just separate themselves with truth and
just go for the [ __ ] money they don't
give a [ __ ] about what's right or none
of em give a [ __ ] they just saying [ __ ]
to say [ __ ]
so idiots like me get upset and yell at
their [ __ ] TV and keep watching and
then what are they did they get some
more habit - Sheree right they date they
you know they get they get a bigger
[ __ ] coming over the [ __ ] is there
after over there a new tie tech I don't
know I don't know what motivates people
that want to sit around in suits talking
about sports why do they wear suits by
the way can anybody explain that to me
why are they all sitting there like
they're on Meet the Press when they talk
I just I don't [ __ ] understand it you
know and it's contagious talking
standing in a [ __ ] suit talking about
sports is so [ __ ] contagious showed
up dressed dare I say dress to the
[ __ ] night he looked like a million
bucks from the [ __ ] neck down his
suit was [ __ ] sharp he had a pocket
square that tie the shirt the whole
[ __ ] thing he was killing it okay Oh
Jay would have got off this a second
time if he wore that [ __ ] suit he had
on Sunday however from the neck up he
just look at him going like this guy
crushes a 12-pack while eating all right
of french fries I know he does okay why
you know you know what he looked like he
looked like a guy aqui look like a
convicted drunk driver trying to get his
license back
you promised me you're not gonna do this
again yes your honor
absolutely I've seen the error of my
ways you know still all puffy
I'm [ __ ] with you I love Ben Ben
Roethlisberger but seeing him in a suit
you know
he was he was all grown up I'm proud of
him
sir my apologies the Atlanta Falcons and
I'm not gonna know anybody's [ __ ]
names okay I don't know anybody's names
I know Julio Jones and I know Sherman
you know who Julio Jones made look he
made him look I wouldn't I would never
say regular cuz Sherman is the [ __ ] he
made him look a little bit and I've
never seen him do that because that guy
still shuts down his part of the [ __ ]
field all right and he made him look
kind of bad you know this guy he's
pretty good he's got some pretty good
footwork there then also I thought he
went cab Chancellor came up well he
usually just [ __ ] lays the [ __ ] and
lover Julio Jones dropped his shoulder
absorbed the [ __ ] and dare I say I'm not
gonna say he put cam on his back but it
was not an issue that cam hit him and
that really surprised me and I don't
know I don't know any the [ __ ] names
I say Atlanta's [ __ ] running back
whatever the [ __ ] his name is the one
who doesn't pretend to eat cereal
whenever he [ __ ] gets a few yards
that's the Cowboys one he gets up you
know you know gu ever seen a guy
campaign and harder to get a Lipton supe
AB you know is that guy who used to be
on the Giants and then did the show at
that little cutiepie in the morning and
then for some reason left that show to
be one of 19 with the guy I used to run
[ __ ] Clinton's campaign is it George
Stephanopoulos on a morning show right
now like that guy's got to be like what
the [ __ ] what happened what I twenty
five [ __ ] years ago I was dealing
with the Russians now [ __ ] sitting
here on pancake Wednesday acting like
I'm excited about this [ __ ] sit on his
[ __ ] couch you know what the worst
parts of those shows are is the way they
decorate the coffee table
you know I can't imagine trudging in
there every [ __ ] day to do that show
like what [ __ ] monkey suit are they
putting you in today you know the girls
have to have their sassy I'm a morning
person outfits you know the guys have to
have that you know I'd show up and you
know I turned the whole [ __ ] paycheck
over to you would pull some Angela's
Ashes shitty and go to the pub instead
they got to have that
and look you know what I mean why did
Strahan leave that show with that little
cutie pie what the [ __ ] is her name I
saw once in real life she's [ __ ]
smoking smoking hot right it was just
the two of them they had a great time
right she come out on his shoulder like
a parakeet he through the monologue
she'd giggle alarm and they had the
whole [ __ ] thing it was just a tool
and then for some reason he leaves that
show Michael Strahan arguably one of the
most successful people you know people
look at Mark Cuban and they go Amy
here's a guy you know he didn't have any
[ __ ] money start some Internet
company makes his sylia dollars that he
buys an NBA team right he starts to go
bald he gets the [ __ ] hair plugs he
goes to Vegas he's had a rave you don't
know where this guy's going he's got his
own [ __ ] jet everybody thinks this is
the guy this is the next [ __ ] Bill
Gates guy he's on Shark Tank okay he's
having people coming in who could barely
afford the gas and their lawnmower and
he's listening to their ideas and then
owning them and then taking them and not
giving it you know you know what guys
like that do right I don't know why I'm
picking on this guy he's just funny to
me right
I'll go of this everybody thinks he's
the next Bill Gates and meanwhile you
got Michael Strahan okay who came up
from the hard streets of somewhere I
don't know where he came from but I know
he's african-american so I know his
streets weren't soft right when was the
last time you saw an african-american
make it and they and they said they did
not come from hard streets that he came
from soft streets you never see that you
do not see there are no soft streets on
that side of the [ __ ] fence so he
came from the hard streets I'm aware
where we gonna put that he doesn't seem
like a New York guy he seems like a
Pennsylvania dude I don't know where the
[ __ ] kid the hard streets of
Harrisburg Pennsylvania Allentown I
don't know where the [ __ ] he came from
whatever he [ __ ] makes it okay he
becomes a [ __ ] superstar right he
deals with Tiki Barbara and whatever the
[ __ ] he was trying to do you know throw
in the ball oh all over the carpet
retires early
they get him out of the way it goes into
the Super Bowl No whoa back up [ __ ]
gets the sack record right you know and
his last one of course was the most
impressive which Brett Favre's run on
that was the precursor to the but fumble
it's the exact same body motion except
he didn't run into a giant offensive
lineman's ass he just came in and just
sort of laid down all right then if I
remember correctly where the [ __ ] did
they go they went somewhere on the road
and won then they went into Green Bay
and won and they went into Dallas in one
I might have those two flip-flops and
then they went to the Super Bowl played
the Patriots and they [ __ ] kicked the
[ __ ] out of him on the offensive like
one on the last [ __ ] play of the game
okay and when's it [ __ ] Super Bowl
then you think that's it no now he goes
no he's a broadcaster - he's [ __ ]
killing it
yeah but you know a lot of guys done
that alley long did it Terry Bradshaw
did it [ __ ] you know Jay Simpson did it
everybody [ __ ] it did it right that's
just what you do if you can actually
[ __ ] and talk about the game and you can
put on a goddamn suit then he does the
unprecedent okay a visionary move then
not even Mark Cuban could come up with
he decides that you know what I am the I
am the next logical choice to take over
for [ __ ] Regis Philbin right I mean I
did a whole bit about Arnold
Schwarzenegger one time about all of his
accomplishments I would put I put
Strahan right there okay and then he
[ __ ] what does he do what does he do
he gets everything's going great for
whatever [ __ ] reason he decides to
join The Partridge Family on some other
[ __ ] morning show it's gonna be the
same [ __ ] standing around watching
somebody cooked something right talking
about how some [ __ ] person just had
their 150 why would you want to be over
there with all of those [ __ ] ass
heads you know all of those different
personalities you know someone's gonna
be a [ __ ] right you could have just
stayed at your other show have you ever
heard somebody waste more time talking
about something that nobody gives a [ __ ]
about in your life I don't know what the
hell that was that was 10 minutes on
Michael Strahan alright um probably like
6 but it felt like 50 so my apology
so that Dirty Birds down in Atlanta I
apologize for disrespecting your team I
didn't realize how good you guys were I
wrote you guys off again at the
beginning of the game when I heard you
had that you know you scored the most
points but were the worst in the league
in the red zone I'm like well that
game's over the game is [ __ ] over so
you run up a bunch of points during the
regular season against 90% of the teams
that are not going to make the playoffs
so that's out the window and then
meanwhile you couldn't stop a hundred
percent of these [ __ ] in the red zone
right there that's a formula for
disaster and what did they do they went
out they beat Seattle so bad there
wasn't one point during that game I
think me on the first drive I saw Pete
Carroll one time when that was it that
was it oh man I love to eat Kelvin he's
a [ __ ] great coach you know he was
[ __ ] pissed when they lost oh he was
[ __ ] pissed can you imagine his
family dog he seems like he'd have a
little one toe just standing there
quivering in the corner people walking
around with his ridiculously white
brand-new socks
walking across his carpeted floor that's
what he seems like to make right has on
his [ __ ] docker PJ's that dog just
gets a little too close you know I don't
understand why we didn't shut up down
defense [ __ ] thing goes flying into
the fireplace anyways it's probably cat
person who knows and my apology to the
Texas a Houston Texans who without Jay
Jay [ __ ] Hamas and a rookie
quarterback hung with the New England
Patriots for uh for three-and-a-half
[ __ ] quarters
yeah I was not impressed with us I don't
think any Patriot fan was uh we'll see
we'll see I hope that's not I think I'm
just hoping our offensive line at a bad
game ever just had a bad [ __ ] game if
you're gonna have a bad game you might
as well do it against the team that's
missing their best offensive player and
has a brand new guy quarterback so maybe
we got away with one I have no [ __ ]
idea all I know is were playing
Pittsburgh next week and I have no
[ __ ] confidence in that despite the
fact Pittsburgh you know I don't know
what they did like they they kicked six
field goals which is essential
you know I don't know if you just went
on field goals you might as well have
somebody out there on like those figure
skates you know dressed up like Yogi
Bear or some [ __ ] was like some ice
capade shits but they they did it
you know they beat Kansas City I didn't
see one second of the game
I watched the beginning of the Dallas
Green Bay game and then at my wife
wanted to go to the movies so I took her
to the movies and I'm like all right I'm
recording this game let's recorded the
[ __ ] Steelers Kansas City game I saw
hidden [ __ ] fig yes and then I came
back right and like all right you know
my wife's taking a bath everything's
[ __ ] cool I go to pop on the Green
Bay Dallas game and I didn't [ __ ]
record it let me say it again
I didn't [ __ ] record it it was sound
like an insane half and I'm [ __ ] hats
off to that [ __ ] dude Crosby who I'm
telling you right now that was some Adam
finitary [ __ ] I never even seen finitary
hit that many 50 yarders in one [ __ ]
game forget about hitting one getting
iced and then he's got to kick it again
the guy kicked like 200 yards in field
goals in like four attempts or some [ __ ]
like that
that's the kind of guy that's the kind
of guy right there you give me a book
and you'll get that's kind of guy can
win you a championship right there cuz
all you got [ __ ] room Aaron Rodgers
all he's got now all you got to do is
just get you close and old Twinkletoes
comes running out with balls the size of
the [ __ ] stadium it gives him the old
right there Fred right do you realize
how much [ __ ] ass he got after that
game even in Dallas
you know those Dallas women with their
[ __ ] Botox and the same amount of
makeup as an 80 year old who can't admit
that she's old you know they all came
running out right took their hats off
take them boots off you know they all
drop to the knees and their designer
[ __ ] Jordache jeans
yeah you ever been to Dallas that this
is this - so far behind in the Styles
you would even think that there's the
internet anymore
they all dress like Dallas is still on
TV the TV show you know bah bah bah I'm
not saying they look they don't really
do that but the through line of that is
still there there's a lot of Larry
Hagman in that city with the -
of dead JFK that is Dallas and there's a
lot of shiny [ __ ] four-door pickup
trucks
you know I don't know who they're driven
by but you know I think you got to get
on the outskirts to get to them or
answers that got them Longhorns walking
and stomping around in the back I mean
my apologies to Meryl Streep evidently
somebody had a hissy fit on the [ __ ]
Twitter telling me that I am a typical
What did he say postmodern cynic or I
just criticize and I offer no solutions
which is hilarious to me it's like okay
so in your world Meryl Streep and myself
should be coming up with problems
problem solving things you would say I
just took tweet of the guy backers I
answer sob as a comedian making fun of
[ __ ] I didn't know as a postmodern cynic
yeah some people that the level of
critic that they give people who don't
even watch the news is just [ __ ]
beyond me I had to go to summer school
every year of high school except
sophomore year because my teacher hooked
me up with a d-minus and my senior year
I just didn't give a [ __ ] and didn't go
you know what I'm gonna do I'm done it's
over I'm a loser all right by him on my
all right so um I know way too much
football how about some hockey just one
quick mention all right did anybody see
Adam McQuaid's fight when they [ __ ]
against Nashville Jesus Christ Jesus cry
I don't know the name of the guy he
fought but that guy's got [ __ ] balls
bigger than my giant head anybody's got
the balls to drop the gloves I'm not
[ __ ] on the guy I just Adam a quake
that [ __ ] guy can fight Eagles like
what - what - what does and then the guy
ducked down and he [ __ ] didn't I
thought it was an uppercut that when I
watching slow-motion I think it might
have been a hook I don't know it just
reminded me in a very very junior way of
when Clark gillies [ __ ] broke that
guy's face he was pounding this guy so
bad the guy just ducked down and right
as he ducked down gillies just went
uppercut and his fist was big enough to
cover the guy's whole face and it was
like it was like he punched a glass
coffee table and this guy just went he
like straight down like when they pull a
building you know and the first time I
noticed that that guy could fight was he
beat the [ __ ] out of Ralphie Torres when
he was playing with Phoenix Coyotes I'll
have links to those fights but that's
that's our I guess he is our enforcer
now and what's great is he's a [ __ ]
unbelievable defenseman too so that's it
Celtics what are we doing we're doing we
always do we beat the pretenders and we
can't beat the contenders that's our
deal and enough sports all right let me
show you a little bit of advertising for
you huh but everything I guess you have
to apologize to Meryl Streep you know
cuz I guess I preached also on my
podcast which is the same as hijacking
an award show right did Meryl Streep
once say hey I'm a [ __ ] [ __ ] what do
I know I don't think she did all right
Oh Billie Street okay here we go let's
read a little oh jesus here we go met up
up up me undies Biondi swearing in
[ __ ] Trump booby undies biondi's
makes you want to take a dump but don't
[ __ ] worries you ball will be soft
they don't care that you got a lot of
[ __ ] in the back it has a trapdoor that
you open up like old long underwear
oh Jesus alright the Valentine's Day
gift oh this Valentine's Day give a gift
that they can unwrap again and again
matching underwear from me undies no
Jesus who the [ __ ] once all right
Valentine's Day is near and it's time
it's a it's a goat in his goat I'm sorry
for thoughtful gift hunting any words
that have a dash in it like they're
together like it's a team I'm like a
rookie quarterback I can't like you know
I just look at my number one receiver I
can't check down to the next guy and I
just stumble over it it's go time
any word I guess you put a dash there
because I'd be like it's go time it's go
time for thoughtful gift hunting me
undies has you covered with limited
edition also a - matching pairs of
undies for you and yours has Valentine's
Day got you stumped no it doesn't I
don't I don't
given to the crazy emotion of it much
like everybody trying to get me freaked
out that I'm having a kid any minute now
all right forget the cliches and give a
gift that looks great feels great and
will make everyone happy me undies fancy
dinners and chocolate last a night
flowers last a week
Oh shots fired it Sherry's berries and
1-800 flowers me undies gettin all
gangsta rap here in the [ __ ]
beginning of the year this year give the
gift of looking great and feeling great
every day with the world's most
comfortable [ __ ] underwear
heads up Valentine's Days February 14th
case you haven't noticed every [ __ ]
year of your life why are they saying
that like it's [ __ ] Groundhog Day
you know like Easter how that moves
around you know February December 25th
is Jesus's birthday happy birthday to
Jesus right valentine's Day is February
14th well don't panic get your heart on
get your heart on I get it and show some
love with me undies matching undies
we're getting panties his and her
panties this is getting freaky here the
undies are the perfect gift for you and
your Valentine this holiday they're
unbelievably soft and come in limited
edition prints me undies knows that
you're special someone deserves a
special fabric which is why their
underwear is made exclusively out of
mode alpha --dl a fabric with a touch
three times softer than cotton the
undies has this is so [ __ ] creepy
three times softer than cotton come on
everybody get in the van
the undies has a special limited edition
Valentine's uh Valentines undies which
means you and your Valentine can match
and yeah it's as cute as it sounds it
sounds creepy it sounds creepy like it's
even gonna be really like masculine
looking a really feminine looking or are
you just saying it's the same print you
know so you know who's gonna buy these
fun [ __ ] underwear are the kinds of
people that have four kids and I'll name
them by the first consonant these are my
kids
Larry Lauri Leena and they Louie
[Music]
why do people do that and if for some
reason you and me undies aren't a
perfect match they give you your money
back and let you keep the first pair
there's no refund on a bad fancy dinner
duty you're in your [ __ ] house Larry
and you got four kids no Larry that lady
Larry
Lina I didn't was i calling you stuff no
you're beat dad call-to-action they
offer free shipping and for a limited
time listeners to this this station this
station this is the copy that give to
the radio guys chicky King can't give me
a little nod listeners to this podcast
get 20% off their first order but you
have to go to me Andy's calm / / with
the me undies better day guarantee you
have nothing to lose so don't wait any
longer go to me undies calm / burn right
now for 20% off your first order that's
me Eddie's dog comes Ledford if you're
matching underwear I'm gonna go out on a
limb and say the gayest of gay couple I
don't even know that you guys would even
do that would you even be that festive
are gay people festive or is that just a
stereotype that Hollywood is spoon
feeding to America and that's what nice
Dollar Shave Club everybody Dollar Shave
Club always gives you a closed news
shave and you can't beat the convenience
of the price ya don't have to choose
between settling for a cheap bag as
shitty disposable or ratios are paying
out the [ __ ] nose for a razor with
the laser pointer and 17 blades it's
awful then Dollar Shave Club broke onto
the scene with a smarter choice before
Dollar Shave Club there was no middle
ground
it was either shave with your [ __ ]
girlfriends think she did her legs with
and cut up your [ __ ] face so he spent
a zillion dollars no you get those free
ones at the gym which felt like shaving
with a piece of glass there or pay a
fortune for the latest okay I'm just
skipping around a copy if Dollar Shave
Club is the best of both worlds you get
the premium shave quality at the
disposable shave price right it's like
buying a Cadillac for five bucks if you
haven't tried Dollar Shave Club yet
you're missing out it's an amazing shave
and affordable price if you haven't
figured that out yet what the
20 paragraphs a [ __ ] copy there's no
smarter choice on the market right now
they're giving away a one-month trial of
any of their razors for only $1 with
free shipping and after that it's just a
few bucks a month see that like a drug
deal if they give you a little taste of
the crack then you hooked then you're
stealing VCRs there's no long-term
commitments no hidden fees and you can
cancel whenever you want get your adult
your $1 trial at dollarshaveclub.com / /
that's dollarshaveclub.com / / alright
there's two more reeds and I'm seeing
double so I'm gonna take a [ __ ] break
here alright okay what do I want to talk
about here oh you know I was watching
the speaking of Cadillacs Oh whoo yeah
Elvis Presley I was watching the Meachem
autumn autumn autos wait I'm trying to
open these [ __ ] blinds Jesus Christ
come on for [ __ ] sakes how hard does
this have to be there you go [ __ ] a
little light on the subject I was
watching on those Meachem automobile
auctions and I gotta tell you I'm [ __ ]
over the muscle cars
I love muscle cars like any other
red-blooded American you know any
red-blooded American I like those
[ __ ] cars but every [ __ ] what's the
same thing we got some Mopar power
coming up of course you do
oh really does it have a Hemi is that a
Shelby it's the same and what it
basically is is that it's the same
[ __ ] like 20 muscle cars what are you
gonna have what are you gonna have you
know what you're gonna have you're gonna
have a Shelby Mustang you're gonna have
the tri-powered [ __ ] Corvette right
you're gonna have the [ __ ] you're
gonna have a GTO have a [ __ ] uh all
that Mopar [ __ ] Hemi [ __ ] that I
never got into Lowe's never a Chrysler
Dodge Guide Plymouth guy I like the
Barracuda all right they're gonna have a
[ __ ] challenger they can have a
charger they're gonna have a Super Bee
they're gonna have the [ __ ] whatever
that z28 was that the only made [ __ ]
ten of them they're gonna have one of
those it's the same [ __ ] cars over
and over again and mean
while here's my question we the [ __ ]
all the trucks do you know where the
[ __ ] are all the trucks occasionally a
truck will come across trucks our
coolest [ __ ] and where's all those great
old man gangster cars you know like the
[ __ ] my favorite one of all time the
1967 Cadillac Eldorado that [ __ ] car
it just go [ __ ] yourself I love that
[ __ ] car that's the kind of car you
know what I mean that you drive when
you're either post-divorce or you were
smart enough never to get married okay
and you're successful and you're just
[ __ ] driving around and you got you
got you got you got a stable of [ __ ]
and you know they don't give a [ __ ]
about you you don't give a [ __ ] about
them yeah they pay girlfriends that's
the [ __ ] car you have you know and
this is the thing and rather than
secretly being lonely and empty inside
you're actually fulfilled because you
own that car you are the closest thing
to the most interesting man in the world
you know that stay thirsty my friends
you ever seen a woman in his life you
see women when men in his [ __ ] life
you know what I mean you never see him
at a [ __ ] dance recital with his
[ __ ] rug rats
anyways I [ __ ] love that car I hope
that most gangsta [ __ ] car and then I
also liked the 65 Jesus Christ with the
clam shell [ __ ] open the headlights
there Buick Riviera okay and at some
point that might be my next car when I
Drive the Jag into the ground by the way
I sold my Prius today I had that [ __ ]
for nine years man boohoo it's great I
never did that boy never sold it to just
a person I always traded him in and this
time I actually sold it to a person that
the title did the whole thing felt like
Richard Rawlings you know what does he
say when he fizzy wow somebody right
except was a Prius and I didn't build it
other than that I was just like him
speaking of which the debut of gas
monkey garage is tonight and rumor
has it that the bearded wonder Aaron is
leaving the [ __ ] show which is you
know that's like Eddie Van Halen leaving
Van Halen or David Lee Roth leaving I
mean it's it's I am you know there's a
lot I'm interested to see what what they
do with this one how you gonna how you
get a make up for that guy Jesus Christ
but I'll be tuning in I'll be tuning in
because that's that's of all the shows
out there that's the best one out there
and there's so many shows that rip that
[ __ ] show off and try to capture that
formula that's the best one out there
and I love the [ __ ] that they built
speaking of trucks last season they were
saying you know what we're all truck
guys we're all truck guys and I'm
yelling at the TV well then [ __ ] make
some more trucks I remember that they
made that one for Casey I can count on
one hand they made the one for Casey
they made that uh they made this Chevy
especially if you get those ones that
had the two-tone paint two-tone paint
Jesus Christ two-tone paint I don't
think if I can finish this I did
two-tone paint you know what that is
that's your taint is the normal your
normal flesh color and somebody tries to
kick you in the balls from behind and
they miss and you get a black and blue
mark on part of your taint then what you
have is a two-tone taint all right -
told paint they and they did last year
what did they do they did a like a 1948
of 49 Chevrolet and they just went all
out what the [ __ ] thing and it was it
was absolutely [ __ ] it was it was it
was just amazing it's amazing what they
do in that show and I wish I had their
skills who knows someday maybe something
I'll [ __ ] have the time to find a
[ __ ] 67 Cadillac Eldorado dragged that
[ __ ] out of somebody's backyard now
somebody like that build a thing for me
I'm one of those guys too I would drive
it I saw one on I hate people get those
[ __ ] cars they don't drive them I got
one for you if you want to look this up
right now all right
look up 1960
five Cadillac Eldorado $45,000 this
[ __ ] guy he's got the best-looking
one I think I've ever seen it has like
somebody did a whole body off
restoration on it has like [ __ ] 33
miles he got it when it had like seven
miles on it and then now he's selling it
with 33 and it's just like why would you
drive that [ __ ] thing to 200,000
miles
unbelievable [ __ ] car but the only
part I will warn you when you watch that
video when he starts caressing the
leather inside the car it gets a little
creepy I had to fast-forward through it
he was like look at that that's fine
Italian leather oh yeah he didn't get
that bad but it got pretty bad but this
[ __ ] guy is got a bunch of them
Supersport motors calm at least he did
as of I guess two years ago two and a
half years ago whenever you put this
[ __ ] video up but if I was gonna buy
one I would buy one off of this guy holy
[ __ ] [ __ ] he's got some beautiful
cars beautiful Cadillacs um
anyways let's plow ahead here I think
maybe it's time to uh maybe it's time to
do a little low Trump gets sworn in this
week you know he gets [ __ ] sworn in
and uh I would feel so much better about
that guy you know it's it's not the
racist people that he's putting in there
you know is unsettling as that is I mean
everybody's [ __ ] racist you know well
that's not true
there's different degrees of it but
everybody has it even people who are
victims of it they have it you look at
another group of people you everybody's
done that you look at a group of people
you think something like oh it's like
this and then you go over there oh it's
actually like that Wow why did I think
that and it all was in your [ __ ] head
you know I got to do a bit about this I
was driving down the street the other
day by doing with a Duke right driving
down the street and I see this group of
young kids like school just let out
right this is not a good sign right here
I'm driving by a school right when the
school got out I'm caressing my leather
no I'm driving down the street and these
kids are all outside like it's right
around the corner from where I'm playing
drums here's my alibi I swear to God is
playing drums around the
and it's one of those stores that sells
like you know all the [ __ ] snacks and
[ __ ] that you eat afterwards you get all
[ __ ] wired so I'm driving by there
and usually I get [ __ ] annoyed
because the kids are [ __ ] walking
across the street then out looking both
ways and all that [ __ ] and then I it
takes me forever to make a [ __ ] left
or right hand turn well this day they
were all up on the sidewalk and I saw
this movement I kind of glanced over and
none of the kids were white and when I
saw this action I thought I was watching
somebody getting the [ __ ] kicked out of
them potentially getting beaten into a
gang that's what my brain told me I was
watching when I looked closer there was
like seven kids standing around one kid
looking at a [ __ ] smartphone and then
some other kids just sort of [ __ ] you
know doing whatever running around in
the background then I was thinking why
the [ __ ] did I just think that you know
so before you [ __ ] call all these
[ __ ] all these races [ __ ] you
know you got to get that [ __ ] out of
your head I was thinking why the [ __ ]
did I think that part of that is from
the [ __ ] that I see on TV right I think
your brain just goes it once it gets
tough down like how to make cereal it
just gets it down like okay just grab
this [ __ ] and put this in and then you
go [ __ ] cereal you know it connects
to one I want vision to this this this
and it's like a motive like survival
which works but in that instant that
didn't work did it I went from that to a
couple of [ __ ] ice cube videos or
whatever gangster rap videos are my head
[ __ ] that I saw in the news right they
can't say there was fear there was no
fear I was just driving down the street
and I looked and that's what I thought
you know but I kind of do that all the
time you know I read a kids book to my
unborn daughter last night right it's
supposed to make him smarter right and I
was reading this kid's book and halfway
through the book I realized I didn't I
had no [ __ ] idea what it was about so
maybe I'm just a [ __ ] I have no idea
but seeing I what a flawed [ __ ]
person I am I can't judge I can only
judge people so [ __ ] harshly right
honestly I mean I can trash your [ __ ]
Meryl Streep I can go off in a Donald
Trump but at the end of the day I'm a
[ __ ]
tick right I read a kids book and I
couldn't figure out what his about was
about this [ __ ] caterpillar all right
and they were like on day one it ate an
apple on day two at 8:00 two pears on
day three it ate [ __ ] three plums
right so right there I'm like all right
this is like reverse Christmas story
rather than going like seven swans
a-swimming six geese a-laying it [ __ ]
starts with the [ __ ] tree the
partridge in a pear tree now it's moving
up and it seems to me like it's about
eating healthy and food and Counting and
then it gets up to like twelve or
something and then and the thing just
completely abandons its fruit diet and
said it had a [ __ ] couple slices of
pizza and ice cream and all this [ __ ]
then a big stomachache so then I was
like alright this is about childhood
obesity and I actually lied that had
never dawned on me that it was about
counting India was like finished the
book the thing turned into a butterfly
and I said I said the end and I looked
at me and I said I have no idea what
that [ __ ] book was about she laughed
she goes it's about counting I go it's
not about not eating junk food cuz it
ate all that fruit and everything was
fine and then it ate all that other [ __ ]
then it got sick and she was like crying
laughing at me I don't know what that
has to do with Trump but I really wish
that idiot would get off a [ __ ]
Twitter but he's a [ __ ] mess he said
about China it's time to take the gloves
off he he's doing that George Bush thing
will you talk about other countries like
you're trying to psyche somebody out
before a bar fight and nothing gets
people more excited you know a kid that
gets morons excited like [ __ ] idiots
he's like trash and SNL cuz they're
doing sketches about him it's just like
I don't I don't I don't
he cannot be running his Twitter account
there's no way he's this [ __ ]
sensitive or he has the time to do this
shouldn't he be addressing it might my
worst fear is that he's going to become
president and just deregulate everything
so he
can build the golf course wherever the
[ __ ] he wants to like that's really
that's his idea of making it great again
III hope I'm [ __ ] wrong I have no idea
having said all that still as much as
he's a nightmare unbelievably
unbelievabl joy watching Hilary loose oh
I love seeing ya
pack your bags okay pack your bags
they're [ __ ] yeah I'm going to say it
alright let's let's let's continue on
all right let's uh I'm off the [ __ ]
rails here all right
forty two minutes in can we can we read
these last two advertise and they'll do
your questions for the week
all right helix Alex hey by the way why
don't you guys send those in send in
your I looked at this thought it was
this way and then it was another way but
nobody heard me say it so everybody
thinks I'm a great guy and that goes for
non-white ease - cuz I know you lookin
at us or some other group of people
Koreans or some [ __ ] or whatever you
know I know you're thinking something
alright Alex helix alright you're unique
and I actually you know as much as I'm
I'm not really joking around about this
[ __ ] but I think that people have to be
able to say that they have those [ __ ]
thoughts I mean this [ __ ] progressive
left thing well you have to act like
you're just walking around going I don't
see color I don't care if you're black
white green or purple and it's all of
those all of that [ __ ] sing-songy
horse [ __ ] even those people even those
people like you get him in the wrong
situation and the fear comes up they're
gonna think something [ __ ] up they're
gonna all right so if you have any those
stories I want to hear I want to hear
and then I'll try to well I'll try to
guess why you think that way okay so I'm
guessing with mine it's the news and all
the gangster rap videos that I used to
watch and I'm old so that was back when
you could actually have a gun in the
video and then also I think I've watched
too many of those life on the inside
prison things you know what I mean all
of those things where you just look at
it and going like I would last 15
seconds in there I've watched all those
ones about gangs I've watched the ones
about motorcycle gangs
it's probably my
my intake of television and YouTube
videos I watch videos of people sucker
punching people bully fails I watch a
lot of violence yeah that's it maybe
that's what it is all right HELOCs helix
you're unique you know walk like anyone
else talk like anyone else anyone else
asleep like anyone else so why is your
mattress one-size-fits-all because a
truly customized mattress will cost you
five to ten thousand bucks until now go
to helix sleep calm answer a few simple
questions and they'll run a 3d
biomechanical model of your body and how
will they do that through the
proprietary algorithms they've developed
with the help of the world's leading ear
ear girl nam --ax and biomechanics
experts the results they they build a
[ __ ] robot to take your place but in
the meantime you sleep on the most
comfortable mattress you've ever slept
on HELOCs customers report a 30%
improvement in overall sleep quality and
for couples they customize each side of
the mattress your mattress arrives at a
door at your door in about a week and
shipping is on a percent free that's why
everyone from GQ magazine to Forbes are
all talking about helix sleep you have
100 nights to try it out if you don't
like it they'll pick it up for free
and give you a 100% refund no questions
asked do it I would dress like I'm [ __ ]
[ __ ] beekeeper when I pick that thing
up go to helix sleep calm slash burn get
$50 off your order that's hellix sleep
calm / / excel-like sleep calm / bar
alright lastly but not leastly stamps
calm you know one great resolution you
can make for the new year maximizing
every minute and every dollar for your
small business I know an easy way to do
that stamps.com stamps.com is the better
way to get postage just use what you
already have your computer your printer
and your [ __ ] fingers to get official
US postage for any package or letter
then the mailman picks it up the mail
man everything you would do at the post
office you can do right from your desk
and at a fraction of the cost of one of
those expensive postage meters you stamp
stock comps whenever I send out my
posters you know whenever I'm whoring
myself out at the end of the show you
know
[ __ ] shake hands that have been
sneezed into right now sign up for
stamps commie used my promo code BIR for
this special offer four week trial plus
$110 bonus offer that includes a post
including postage and digital stale
scale go to stamps com before you do
anything else click on the microphone at
the top of the homepage and type in /
that stamps comm enter ber all right
that is it all right let's read some of
the questions here for the week and then
I can get the full caddy
all right team relocating dear Billy
Brady balls my NFL team I've rooted for
over 20 years is moving to LA
parenthesis Chargers what team should I
root for Patriots are out of the
question
Thanks and [ __ ] the Spanos family first
of all my condolences
I remember Jesus almost 25 years ago
when Robert Kraft first bought the team
and he was threated some point maybe it
was in the in the year 2000
somewhere around then he was [ __ ]
threatening to move the team to Hartford
if he didn't get his own stadium and
[ __ ] and that really is one of the
biggest you know [ __ ] overs by all of
these sports leagues that they get the
cities that we have to pay for their
[ __ ] stadium that's a time when you
need a union if you could just have a
somehow have a union of all sports fans
they'd be like now you [ __ ] pay for
it you [ __ ] pay for a new stadium you
[ __ ] you know what I mean I go to the
ice cream store to have to buy a new
[ __ ] store when they want a new store
they pay for it but the money they made
off of ice cream like how much money do
you have to make do you know when I was
in [ __ ] Indianapolis those poor
bastards that live out there I don't
know if this is still the case but when
I went out there when they were putting
that Lucas Oil Field deal together when
they were already paying for that they
still had not paid off the RCA Dome or
the Hoosier dome whatever the [ __ ] they
called it they were still paying for
that other one and this [ __ ] Kant
made him buy another one I haven't said
that I guess I can't get mad at the
Spyros family if everybody else is
getting a new stadium and he wasn't able
to
male Sandiego you know a good few San
Diego [ __ ] him
you want to do stadium once you're
packing bags up and get the [ __ ] out of
here
but you guys also kind of [ __ ] up the
way Cleveland did you can't buy one team
a stadium and then tell the other guys
to go [ __ ] themselves
that's like in Cleveland when they the
Jake got built and then whatever his
[ __ ] name was the [ __ ] was that guy's
name
everybody in Cleveland screaming it
right now who sounded exactly like
George see Scott exact same voice yeah
he wanted a stadium you know like yeah
[ __ ] you you can stay in that absolute
[ __ ] [ __ ] anything he left say
yeah it's not personal just business
why can I keep thinking good Dell I'm a
Patriots fan that's all I think when I
think of a [ __ ] [ __ ] I just think
Roger Goodell yeah that sucks man so we
should you vote for you know what I do I
would say [ __ ] the NFL if the Patriots
ever left I would just say [ __ ] the NFL
I would be done with it and I would just
pick a college team college football is
to [ __ ] you know even though the
athletes college sports are great but
the athletes get [ __ ] over that they
don't get paid the fact that they sell
in $100,000 Stadium and then [ __ ]
idiots oh and it's always non-athletic
people who say this go there get a free
education I'll do they like they have
time to [ __ ] go to class you're
majoring in football there's too much
money at stake and all these in all the
nerds that don't like the jocks at the
college level it's like if it wasn't for
that football program you would be going
to science class in a [ __ ] tent a
hundred thousand people are not gonna
show up to watch you look through a
microscope don't ever forget that all
right so why don't you [ __ ] put on
your lab coat and go figure out how to
make a better football cleat oh Jesus
bill there's no reason to go that hard
was there can't we have respect for all
of the Arts Meryl Streep doesn't she
doesn't respect mixed martial arts hey
Meryl why don't you tell us what the
arts are Jesus Christ because there's
not a symphony behind it you
that watch NFL film that's art the music
they put behind it ynette weina weina
weina weina weina weina alright movie
foods videos hey there Billy egg-whites
saw this guy's videos on YouTube he
makes food from different famous movies
that's pretty cool in this one he makes
the Big Kahuna burger from pulp fiction
which is pretty basic but another's he
does some cool ship [ __ ] from chef one
of my favorite movies in the last few
years in Aceh the cartoon I highly
recommend checking a few of them out he
makes a couple of sandwiches that would
give your grill top some great use ah
dude that's awesome thank you look at
that no question
just great information I guess I never
tell you guys you can also do that
that's [ __ ] cool as hell I will
definitely check that out I have been
cooking up a [ __ ] storm you know cuz
we can't really go anywhere every once a
while take me out to the movies which
this weekend this past week I saw
moonlight and I saw hidden figures and I
really liked both for different hidden
figures big Hollywood movie you know
totally did the job was great and then i
saw moonlight which was also great and
my favorite part of that [ __ ] movie
now I'm not ruining it no spoiler alert
other unless you're into cars was which
was annoying was this is one part where
they're showing the main character and
then not showing his [ __ ] car but you
can tell it's a nice car I wanted to see
the car and then they finally showed it
that was I believe it was in 83 to 87
Oldsmobile Cutlass and those were those
great two doors that they had in the
[ __ ] 80s there was you know the the
also Beale Cutlass the [ __ ] Chevy
Monte Carlo and the Buick Regal those
[ __ ] cars are the [ __ ] and I know a
lot of those southern guys redo when
they put the big tires on them I don't
like the big tires on them but that's
another one that
sort of a poor man's [ __ ] Eldorado
but I love those and some of the
funniest like guys I knew when I was
growing up had those [ __ ] cars just
anybody who had a car like that was a
[ __ ] was it was a good [ __ ] as they
say in Massachusetts you know and slash
a little bit shady probably dealing a
little bit of weed maybe he had a fight
last night those are all those guys they
go into a bar and within ten minutes
they eyeballing somebody and then they
gotta take the chain off cuz they're
gonna get into a fight remember that the
80s that would take you [ __ ] chain off
with dog and tonight I think the chains
coming back I think it's making a
comeback
anyways really enjoyed both of those
movies moonlight I really [ __ ] that
was it that classic just independent
movie where it was like it didn't [ __ ]
lead year-round to the by the nose like
and here's the next one and here's the
next point you then here's the next plot
point really good movie alright Putin
Russian hacking all right this guy is
writing about Russian hacking and he
start look is that we start this guy
started his [ __ ] he just started his
[ __ ] uh his email to me with look
he's already wagging his finger at me
Jesus Christ dude relax he says look
international politics between two
countries with enough nukes to destroy
the earth ten times over is no laughing
matter
Oh am I not supposed to joke about it
how come you aren't all over this orange
clown I don't understand what this do
you want jokes about it sure Clinton was
no prize but you're willing to give
Putin and and out-and-out gangster a
pass oh I don't remember him running for
president of the United States what are
you talking about what kind of world is
going to be there for your new child oh
shut the [ __ ] up
I [ __ ] hate when people okay new
world is going to be there for your kid
the same world that was there when I was
a kid
progressively getting worse like what is
your [ __ ] solution there's no
solution to this [ __ ] you got seven
billion people all running and [ __ ]
200 million different directions it's a
[ __ ] show all right the second we
weren't one tribe it was over it's over
second there was two tribes
it was [ __ ] over whenever we started
out right let's just say that I don't
subscribe that there was a [ __ ] and
Adam and and Eve I think there was a
pond and there was a bunch of us that
came out of something according to Neil
deGrasse Tyson it was the [ __ ] trees
other people say it was the [ __ ]
ocean whatever the [ __ ] it was there was
a bunch of you can't have a man and a
woman banging and then that kids [ __ ]
without having major problems alright
well maybe that's why cavemen looked
like they did I have no idea but
whenever we all weren't sort of
cohabitating together but you know what
happened is anyways we came along there
was no language it was just uh well that
[ __ ] of course it was gonna be [ __ ]
arguments everybody grunting and
groaning you know I have no idea like we
were [ __ ] this thing was [ __ ] from
day one okay and I've gone down the
rabbit hole of trying to [ __ ] give a
[ __ ] and trying to you know I don't get
people to listen to my opinion which
probably has 0.1% of 1% of the
information that I need to actually make
an even remotely informed opinion you
know I mean look at all those guys on TV
who do it for a [ __ ] living from from
Bill Maher to Bill O'Reilly okay even
those guys as much as they pay attention
are severely handicapped by the fact
that they cannot look at tucks
top-secret documents to kind of you know
connect the dots all you all you can do
is watch the [ __ ] news read
newspapers and try to figure out which
one seems to be sort of making sense
with what the [ __ ] you're thinking
that's the best you can do sir so I
don't know what you want for me but I'll
continue reading this
this isn't like telling jokes to a few
middle Millennials in a strip mall
it's not funny that Trump and his swamp
full of white racist rich men are
robbing us blind I agree with that but
you realized that Hillary Clinton in
2008 after the banks went under went and
gave them a speech and said don't worry
I got you guys
those aren't those the same rich racist
white people you know isn't that the
same upper 1% you know that you're
talking about here just saying they are
you know by the way that the upper 1% no
matter who wins they win you understand
that right
the job pays 500 grand a year it takes a
hundred million to get okay and then
they owe these [ __ ] favors that got him
in office they push it through they
deregulate stuff they looked the other
way they granted government contracts
all of that [ __ ] and then once they're
done being president you watch with
Obama he's gonna make a fuckload of
money going around air-quote giving
speeches 200 300 grand a night to the
exact same [ __ ] people that put him
in office that's just them washing their
bribe money people with blue ties red
ties red panties blue panties they all
[ __ ] do it except for Jimmy Carter as
far as I can tell he stopped being
President and started going around
building houses for poor people
everybody else sits around waiting for
the [ __ ] library to be built oh my
soapbox give me a Golden Globe all right
just saying they are both bed is really
dropping the ball no it isn't you have
your head in the [ __ ] sand that's
what it is
you just have your head in the [ __ ]
sand I'm from New Jersey and know
several small contractors who were
shorted by Trump and couldn't afford to
sue right and I worked in Atlantic City
and he had a couple casinos go under and
they got paid dimes on the dollar I know
how that works he's a real [ __ ] that
doesn't give a [ __ ] about the little guy
he's got the track record okay okay and
you're saying Hillary Clinton gives a
[ __ ] about the little guy Hillary
Clinton who only swings by the little
guy whenever she needs votes and spends
the rest of time on [ __ ] Martha's
Vineyard
zillions all her [ __ ] house that she
can somehow afford when her husband has
only made [ __ ] at the most 500 grand
a year she got paid as a center where
does that make 175 grand a year they're
making less money than some of the
[ __ ] top comedians in the [ __ ]
world yet they're worth 200 million
dollars how do you do that how do you do
that legally sir tell me tell me how you
do that because you're [ __ ] crooked
all right so there you go and here's the
thing about Russia's spying on us
[ __ ] relax we're doing it to them to
Jesus Christ they shot up planes out of
the sky a spying on them we spy on each
other
abso-fucking-lutely you know that's
that's what we do every [ __ ] thing
that they're doing we're doing they're
[ __ ] with elections we [ __ ] with
elections they're [ __ ] with people in
power putting people in power that
shouldn't be in power we do that they
invade countries we invade countries
they think they're right we think we're
right at the end of the day there's you
and me sitting in [ __ ] Russia regular
[ __ ] people all right that's it it's
just the people atop they get you all
[ __ ] stirred up you know I'm telling
you think it y'all [ __ ] stay gonna
get you they're gonna do it that guy
back at there I don't listen any of it I
don't I just sit and I drink scotch and
I drink myself into a stupor and I stare
at the wall you know and I try to figure
out why I looked at three non-white kids
looking at an iPhone and thought that
someone was getting beaten into a gang
when I solve that first then I'm gonna
move on to trying to solve the world
prompts when I fall when I solve the
problems in the [ __ ] globe that is my
giant [ __ ] head I'll move on to that
and you sir if you're really looking for
somebody to solve the world problems you
should probably look beyond a comedian
doing a podcast where he says [ __ ] every
other word and also says how uninformed
he is okay so you know there you go
agree to disagree but you know if you
want Meryl Streep and [ __ ] little
[ __ ] Billy freckled hands to solve
the world's problems
I think you were trouble anybody can
give the lip service and be like I think
that's absolutely deplorable look I
didn't vote for the [ __ ] guy stop
wagging your finger at me all right all
right plants in the house hey there
Billy ficus I want you to know how I
want to know how you feel about having
plants in the house growing up we always
had plants and cacti in our house I
think they bring a lot of life and color
to a room and it's fun to water and take
care of them I know some people who
would never will have any plants saying
that they bring dirt and bugs in the
house I tell them that it's because they
don't take care of maintain them you
could say the same thing about a dog
saying they [ __ ] and bring fleas into
the house but obviously that student
neglecting and taking care of the dog so
do you have any plants in your home do
you have any in your home now oh do you
like having plants in your home do you
have any home plants in your home now
PS is a total NFL bandwagon fan I'm
calling Green Bay to win it all
all right no I don't like plants in the
house
I had a plant my house one time a long
time ago when I was a complete loner and
I my apartment looked like I was in the
witness protection program I was seeing
this woman and she got me a plant and
immediately I was just like whoa wait
this relationship is moving too fast
what she was trying to do was to get me
to open up and I remember she got me
this plant and then I had to [ __ ]
water it and I kind of liked it but then
I'd go on the road and I would come back
and it would be near death just like you
know hang it down you know staring at
its [ __ ] toes and then I would nurse
it back to [ __ ] health and I would
have ended up having anxiety and then
one day it finally died and I felt this
just ridiculous failure and it was a
metaphor for the whole factor on the
road so much she can't sustain
relationships you can't even keep a
plant alive how you gonna keep a
relationship or a kid alive whose it was
a horrible [ __ ] experience so I don't
might have it in my house if they like
growing like basil or [ __ ] rosemary
or some [ __ ] some some I can eat you
know I'm selfish when it comes to plants
like we got a
bunch of plants around the house I don't
give a [ __ ] about him I'm like Nia why
don't we dig these up and put in some
[ __ ] avocado trees some oranges you
know something that we can eat / throw
it zombies someday what do you say Plus
having trees that grow fruit in your
yard is a great way to figure out who's
your friend and who isn't your friend
especially during the apocalypse when
people come over your fence and try to
steal your food they'll go to the food
like moths to a light and then you can
be on your roof and you can pick them
off with your [ __ ] with whatever
[ __ ] weapon you have right I'd go
with the bow and arrow it's nice and
quiet
right to the neck it was the water that
was the water I mean the blood gushing
out of that [ __ ] what the [ __ ] would
it be call it the [ __ ] artery there
all right plants in the house already
read that one here's the last one
hey Billy [ __ ] tits Jesus lady and I
listened to your podcast religiously I'm
29 years old and I've had roommates
since I moved out of my parents house
when I was 18 I have a history of
anxiety and depression I found that in
addition to taking medicine living with
people really keeps me in check in two
weeks I'm going to be moving into my own
apartment and living by myself with my
dog oh that's [ __ ] awesome that's the
best I love living alone fight a dog -
that would've been tremendous of course
would have died like the [ __ ] plan
right now I live with two guys the three
of us are super close but we've lived
together for three years and it's time
for us to move out of the frat house and
into our own places
I'm nervous about living by myself
because I'm scared that I'm going to
isolate myself and fall back into a
cycle of depression again
I live in Indy so the weather is [ __ ]
right now which doesn't help in the
spring and summer I play intramural
sports football and volleyball I'm very
much a guy's girl and I don't have very
many girlfriends I don't ever have a
ladies night I'd rather sit at a bar
with a beer and watch football or
college basketball I hate dating I am
straight though the gay people hate
dating I don't know I would love to get
your advice for a lady like me moving in
her own apartment for the very first
time what would you suggest I do - stay
social and not sit at home alone
watching the Indiana Hoosiers
and downing Coors Light PS tell me I
said hi and best of luck to you and me
on the new your new baby thanks and go
[ __ ] yourself oh boy you're asking a
[ __ ] loaner I loved when I finally
didn't have to have roommates and I
lived alone I [ __ ] loved it I loved I
talked to myself I talked to the TV I
had a great [ __ ] time and I guess I
was I had a level depression there that
I wasn't really aware of well don't you
get enough sort of interaction in the
springtime you play intramural sports
football volleyball okay so it's the
winter time um I don't know you want to
go sledding I'm trying to think what the
[ __ ] he can do is there an adult League
snowball fight thing you can get
involved in there's got to be something
that you could do well if you're into
sports why don't you just join a fantasy
league with some of your friends but I
think what you are is I think you're a
sweetheart and you're a relationship
person you're just afraid to do it so
that's why you like having roommates you
don't like being alone I'm totally
guessing here by the way I don't [ __ ]
know you but I think I think it's time
to give Dayton a try you know I would do
that maybe you're afraid of doing that I
would I think this seems like you need
to face a fear and look at this living
alone as an opportunity thing and that
this is the next logical step to finding
the person you want to be with in life
if that's what you're looking for so I
would embrace living alone and I'll
[ __ ] awesome that is and decorate
your apartment don't do what I did you
know have some color in there and Huff
that type of [ __ ] something upbeat
and I would become social I would have
people over to your place you don't know
if you cook there's a zillion things you
could do you just have to make the
effort I don't know why you don't have
many girlfriends but it sounds like you
do have some girlfriends so you only
need a couple of friends I would open up
to your friends rather than some psycho
on a podcast not saying this was a bad
move but it's a nice step I would open
up to them
say listen I'm prone to depression so
I'm worried that when I live alone that
I'm going to become depressed you know
if you'd like to swing by and watch a
game with me
bla bla bla bla bla I would do that I
would be open and honest and maybe go
talk to somebody about your depression
so you don't go down that [ __ ] rabbit
hole but it's great that you know that
you're depressed and that you need to do
something about it so that you're way
ahead of the game as opposed to where I
was where I didn't know I was depressed
and I [ __ ] know no it made a lot of
stupid [ __ ] moves for a long time
alright that's the podcast for this week
thank you so much for listening and I'll
post that video of that cadillac
eldorado it's [ __ ] beautiful alright
go [ __ ] yourselves and I'll talk to you
on Thursday